all right there has been a lot of
activity on the David Pakman show
discussion forum on reddit which you can
check out by going to david pakman.com
slash read it re d di t record traffic
continuing on the record discussion
forum but less trolling interestingly
enough reddit a known hub of trolling a
lot of trolling during november and the
earlier part of december but lately i've
been noticing less trolling on our
discussion forum i don't know if it's
that the trolls are receding or that the
auto spam filters maybe are recognizing
some of the trolls and preemptively
blocking them here's a few interesting
discussions from the reddit discussion
forum that i hope you will participate
in and join us on let's take a look at
the first one here there was a link to
an article in political called putin's
real long game i haven't read the
article yet but i've bookmarked it and a
big discussion about that on the david
pakman show reddit what what is the real
long-term goal here of vladimir putin
another discussion from the reddit
discussion forum Julian Assange says
Obama is trying to do gitam eyes Trump
with the Russian hack claims they linked
to a Daily Caller article in a
discussion about that a lot of
discussion on the reddit discussion
forum about the entire Russian hacking
story and and much much more will be
said I'm sure story number three from
the reddit discussion forum CNN uses
video game footage to show how Russian
hackers breached the DNC in Podesta
emails yet I ended up not doing the
story on the show because I didn't feel
like I had too much to add but it's an
interesting little story a video game
footage used to talk about Russian
hacking on CNN yeah that video game is
from fallout i'm pretty sure it's all
outfit yeah uh okay continuing with
recent discussions on our discussion
forum deportation there was a question
raised of why is it that deporting
illegal aliens who are also criminals a
controversial position on the left a
question that many on the discussion
forum found to be biased at its core but
it led to an interesting discussion
nonetheless continuing with threads from
our reddit discussion forum a challenge
can the progressives from the david
pakman show subreddit complete a video
of
feminist slam poetry and there is a link
to some uh talk to I guess what's a
feminist poetry slam not exactly what I
watch on YouTube regularly but hey if
you're interested in that type of thing
there was a opportunity to check it out
next we have uh another post about our
story regarding does pro diversity come
off as anti white and a very long and
detailed post about the caller who asked
about this on the show really
interesting discussion there that you
can check out as well and I believe we
have no more that's it so some of the
recent discussions from the david pakman
show reddit forum check it out sign up
david pakman.com slash reddit interview
suggestions whatever's on your mind the
david pakman show reddit discussion
forum is a great spot